have you ever talked anybody
metaphorically down from the ledge you
know where they're thinking of giving up
and you've just given them the same
piece of information that you've given
us I don't know if I I certainly didn't
know what at the time there was one
woman that a long time after it happened
thanked me privately for you know
spending some time talking with her and
kind of talking her down I mean she's
just that had it
I remember the long conversation we had
on the telephone about you know why this
business sucked and there was no no
opportunity for advancement for her and
nothing was working and she just felt
like she was on a hamster wheel and
going nowhere and I said you know that
that may be true and it may not be true
you you may never go anywhere but you're
not gonna find out unless you stay and
try because it could happen tomorrow it
could happen tomorrow that's what
happened to me I mean I was just kind of
a workaday co-star occasional guest star
guy until I was brought in to audition
for an HBO show on a Saturday Saturday
that's very inconvenient for me I really
don't want to go into an audition on a
Saturday because I play softball on
Saturdays and maybe they'll do it a
different day agent can you get me in a
different day
no they're just doing it on Saturdays
all right all right I went in and there
were 50 other guys there and they all
look like me on on oh jeez this is
ridiculous but it did my did my job in
the room and then I came back and I came
back again and the herd thinned and
thinned and thinned and thinned and
finally make a long story short I was
cast as ed haligan in Funny or Die
presents and Liz Paulson brought me in
for that for that role and that show
produced by Will Ferrell which was sort
of the TV version of the funnier
website changed everything for me it put
me on radars that I previously had not
been lovin and opened a lot of doors for
me and created opportunities that I
never would have had had Liz not brought
me in for that well I will forever be
grateful to her for that yeah and and
and to just to finish the thought if you
don't stay and wait for that opportunity
you won't know so yeah that that woman
and I had a very long conversation that
night but I you know I didn't I was just
trying to give her a pep talk but it
turned out that it was important to her
and she stayed and she's still here and
working so when did it when did you
realize how much of a choice it was
staying here in terms of like hey it may
not work out but it it may but this is
the choice that I've made and I'm gonna
stick with it even if it doesn't work
out and know that I spent many years
well there's there's another ingredient
of that which is much more ethereal and
and not ethereal but it's harder to
really get a grasp on I think and and
that is a sense of self-awareness you
have to also know when it's time to hang
it up
I don't know how you I don't know how
you quantify that I don't know how you
measure that maybe for me it's just been
I've been too dumb to think that this
isn't an option for me that's not what I
meant maybe it's maybe it's that I've
always felt that there I have some
innate talent in this area not as
talented as other people but I do have
my own set of skills that I bring to the
table and and I think they're worth
something and I'm gonna stick around and
somebody's gonna appreciate them one day
and that's turned out to be true but you
know for some folks that's not that's
not true and they'll probably never be
what they'll never achieve the kind of
success that they think that they should
be achieving in this business and you
know maybe it's maybe it is time to hang
it up at some point but how do you tell
you tell you know when that time is I
don't know I don't know do you ever do
the test of well if I'd rather be
selling annuities I'd be doing it or if
I'd rather you know that if there was
something else that really called to me
I'd probably be doing it or is that a
bad measurement of staying around I've
always wanted to be a fly fishing guide
and sometimes that's been stronger than
the the call to stay in you know the
Performing business so I you know I
don't know but no I think that's I
wouldn't be able to make a living doing
that and it's silly I mean it's a
romantic sort of notion to you know be
out on the river catching trout all day
and
but this is what I love this is what I
love I don't know if I answered your
question at all dude what we've been
talking about how to know if it's time
to quit or give up this has been so
uncomfortable for me this just talking
about it I don't know why but it's very
it's very very uncomfortable because I
can't possibly tell anybody else when
that time is it's something that has to
just come from you know the inside and
someplace that I just don't have access
to in your in your spirit and it's it's
difficult for me to even talk about it I
don't know why look weird
it's very I mean there's there's people
that have achieved amazing success and
you see obviously it wasn't enough
because through self-destruction or
whatever they're no longer here so no
one gets it's a very you know and
everyone some people are just happy
being a working actor that's you know
what's the film that we talked about
that the guy in that thing and it's this
great movie about this documentary about
just actors that just work all the time
and they're recognized but people don't
know their name
and they're very happy with that so you
know with it without all of the baggage
that Fame brings with them so it's a
very that people have different levels
of what they want yeah you know yeah
yeah that's that's true and it is
uncomfortable you know to talk I think
for a lot of people even for in other
words I only know what's right for me
sure and what what the right and wrong
choices for me have been along my career
path and I guess the discomfort comes
from presuming to have any sort of wise
words to tell anybody else about how to
tell when it may be time to stop or
maybe time to just dig in even even
harder and
and hang around I don't know I only only
that person can make that decision
you